from calorie counter portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between skittles in the uk and the us
this is food wars
[Music]
in the uk skittles come in the following
sizes firstly we have these 18 gram fun
sized pouches then we have these 45 gram
bags
then we have a 125 gram bag of skittles
next up is what i think is the most
common size a 152 gram bag then we have
this one a 350 gram mortar share bag
then we have our largest size which is
this one a one kilogram big size share
bag
and in the u.s our skittles come in
these sizes first one the fun size 10
grams we got the 61.5 gram bag next size
99 gram box yeah the movie theater pack
yeah the share size 113.4 grams
first of the resealable bags 204.1 grams
this is the grab and go
255.1 grams
next bag up the sharing size
442.3 grams
the family size
779.6 grams
hey good enough for the egyptians good
enough for us pyramids check them out
this is the party pouch 1.4 kilograms
have you noticed how good i am at
pouring these skittles can this be a job
i get it from getting cocky but i
haven't spilled one
[Music]
the biggest size the jar
1.53 kilograms
now for food wars and general consumer
purposes the one kilogram bag is our
largest size however i did want to point
out this one
a 1.6 kilogram bulk bag i was able to
find one of these online without too
much hassle i think they are more aimed
at like vending machine refills rather
than consumers but yeah you are able to
get 1.6 kilograms of skittles if you are
a massive skittles fan in the uk we also
wanted to check how many skittles you're
getting in each country and also if
there is even color distribution so joe
has asked me to count all of the
skittles in a one kilogram pouch and
we're also going to sort them into
colors to see how many you get what
color order makes the most sense in your
head the rainbow actually has an order
of colors
to me it's a bit of a right roy khabib
vibe more of a cmyk guy harry sort
skittles and asks you about your day
asmr
whoops oh god don't like run around like
their personalities
just keep seeing the yellow and purple
color combination thinking of waluigi
all right
okay i've now sorted them by color it
was satisfying but it did take ages now
we have to count them
all so now we gotta count these and i am
not spending all day counting these so
let's see
i figure out how much 10 skittles weigh
jot that down step two weigh each cup
obviously subtracting the weight of the
cup and then take the weight of each cup
divide by ten six
eight three four
yes
after far too long spent sorting and
counting these we have our final totals
i feel like we learned something but i
don't know exactly what what have we
learned from that uh do not do that at
home it's an enormous waste of time
we did some science today and that is
the most important thing
now well skittles look the same in both
the us and the uk the flavors are
actually different for example in the uk
purple skittles are flavoured with black
currant whereas in the u.s our purple
skittle is grape flavored back in the
early 20th century the us government
made it illegal to grow black currants
because it was spreading a wood
destroying disease now the ban has since
been lifted but black currants never
really became popular as a flavor here
certainly not as popular as grapes when
it comes to tropical skittles in the uk
the colors and flavors are as follows
pineapple
orange
fruit punch
watermelon and passion fruit in the u.s
our tropical skittles flavors are
strawberry star fruit which is pink
mango tangelo which is orange
yellow is banana berry we don't have a
purple one so we have a green one it's
kiwi lime and last here is pineapple
passion fruit which is blue the skittle
flavour controversies continue with our
wild berry skittles in the uk a because
they contain cherry which is very much a
nutterbury and also b because the colors
are all over the place we have cherry in
the purple one apple and blackberry with
the green one blueberry is the light
blue one raspberry is the pink one and
then strawberry and kiwi for the red our
us wildberry flavors are kind of close
to that of the uk's and we too have a
non-berry cherry they even added wild
onto the title but i'm not buying it
berry punch the raspberry which is blue
i don't know why wild cherry which is
not a berry green guy is melonberry and
the pink one at the end here is
strawberry now i had anything to say
about this i think i'd mix the colors up
as well i think in my mind blue
raspberry would make more sense than the
currant blue which is blueberry i think
blueberry would make more sense as the
purple one because as we all know
blueberry isn't actually that blue it is
more of a purple color and then i'd
probably put pink as the cherry one full
flavor lineup oh
and of course we have skittles crazy
sours in the uk our sour skittles are
flavored and colored as follows if sour
cherry is the purple one we have sour
green apple as the green one sour
pineapple is the yellow one sour
raspberry is the pink one and salamander
rin as the orange one in the u.s
skittles sour flavors are also different
so purple is great this one says the
original lime up so i'm assuming green
is now lime yellow is lemon red
strawberry and orange do you think
they're as crazy sour as the packaging
suggests
let's go
a very sane level of sour unfortunately
we reached out to skittles to ask them
about their flavor choices and they
mentioned they had a variety of methods
of picking flavors one of which is
something called social listening which
i assume means checking social media and
due to popular complaints on social
media the green skittle was changed back
to lime after ten ish years of being
green apple with all this talk about
flavors it's worth pointing out that
some people claim that all skittles
might actually taste the same in an
interview with npr neuropsychologist don
katz who specializes in taste said quote
it's cheaper to make things smell and
look different than it is to make them
actually taste different dot dot dot so
skittles have different fragrances and
different colors but they taste exactly
the same this shouldn't come as too much
of a surprise to you because if you've
been stuffed up with a cold or with
allergies you might know that without
your sense of smell food can seem rather
tasteless that's because our sense of
smell is responsible for a large
percentage of what we taste general
flavors like salty bitter sweet sour
those can be detected without smell
however more complex flavors such as
fruit require both taste and smell to be
recognized okay joe i'm curious let me
see how many of these original skittles
i can identify correctly without my
sense of sight or smell so now with the
assistance of you leader joe so i'm
gonna go ahead and do this
and can someone please place five
skittles in front of me uh and i will
see if i can determine mass mass goes
over the nose let's see if i can
determine the flavor ready
no i mean it's my mouth in my face
what is going on with my with my breath
and my mouth and i'm getting pink eye
what if they're all yellow oh my god
you sicko that joe you're gonna try
tricky by repeating flavors
so i blindfolded myself charlie has set
five skittles in front of me i don't
know which colors they are i'm gonna
hold my nose as well eat them and try
and identify them first one
orange
all right wish me luck
i really can't taste much
that's tough wow
i literally just guess i'm gonna go
purple i have no idea all right i need
another one to compare
that let's make it way way harder i
think i got some like more berry vibes
from the second one i think the first
one was a bit more sour so it was either
maybe like an orange or
lemon
it is anything red
that one i don't have a clue about
lemon yellow last one
uh red
this is way tougher than i thought it
would have been i'm gonna go with like
orange
strawberry
lemon green and just uh black crunch
maybe
three out of five how'd i do you got all
of them wrong
i couldn't taste anything you guys want
to try that was a lot harder than i
thought it was going to be i honestly
think if i just saw it and still plugs
it i'd be like yeah i got it orange site
however does not always play a
significant role in identifying flavors
in june 2016 skittles released a limited
edition all-white version of their
product in order to celebrate london
pride they've carried on doing this ever
since stating on the packaging that
during pride only one rainbow matters so
the ditch the rainbow in order to own a
pride month which is a nice gesture on
paper however apparently some people
took this to mean white pride and went
on twitter and voiced said observation
the good news is that despite that most
people did still appreciate the gesture
so they have carried on doing it if
they're all the same color how do you
know which skittle you're getting
it's actually way harder to be like
certain
they have like a fruit flavor to them
but they don't taste like that fruity i
was almost like wait did they also like
omit the flavor
so now because i can't see the color i'm
not quite sure what flavor it is
here are all the skittles products
you'll find in the uk that you won't
find in the us here are all the
exclusive us skittle flavors you cannot
get in the uk we'll start from this end
and work our way along so in the uk we
can get skittles giants now apparently
these are skittles which are three times
the size of regular skittles they do
look pretty beefy i will say they are
similar to the regular uk skittles in
that they still have the hard shell and
they are the same flavors as the normal
ones however apparently they have a
softer inside as well
my issue with this is they do have a
softer inside however it reminds me very
much of chewing gum so everything in my
brain is now screaming at me to not
swallow this i don't think i like that
if for whatever reason you don't like
the crispy shell on your skittles then
we've got you covered because in the uk
you can get skittles chewies which are
skittles without a shell something about
these just looks a little bit
off-putting to me it just kind of looks
like little balls of wax and again
something in your brain kind of screams
at you and says please do not eat this
candle
the flavor doesn't come through as
strongly as it does from a regular
skittle for some reason i feel like they
must have to coat them in something to
prevent them from all just clumping
together in the bag there's something
kind of slimy going on on the tongue
right now which i am not a fan of i'm
disappointed i'm unimpressed this one i
mean is this really a flavor it is the
wild berry and tropical mix flavor
mashups if there's ever been a lazier
exclusive take the two things we already
have stick them in a bag next up we got
shriekers julie beware if you dare
shriekers some are so sour they'll make
you shriek okay
what are you shrieking like is it so
sour you can't handle it it can't be
you're not sure no one has shrieked once
so these are expired in may
we have the america mix no one is more
patriotic than i i bleed red white and
blue mostly red but this feels a little
condescending because it looks like they
just put the flag out like what's the
america mix five flavors three colors
oh these are stale yeah they might have
done this like several years ago last
exclusive flavor we have bright side
skittles remember that song mr
brightside
i look just like mr brightside i love
the black keys but it's kiwi banana
watermelon paradise punch tangerine and
pink lemonade that sounds a lot like the
tropical mix doesn't it these are dusty
compared to
a seemingly much fresher usa one
i should have googled how old these are
it does these taste this tastes like
shampoo our next uk exclusive is squishy
clouds it's another product from
skittles in which they have kind of
ditched the shell and gone for a more
soft chewy approach in the uk these come
in both the standard flavors and also
the crazy sours flavors i don't know
what i was expecting but we have these
kind of very soft pillowy i guess
skittles it feels weird to call this a
skittle but
i prefer these to the other two that
i've just tried so as you can see the
sour version has this kind of like
granulated sugar exterior
whereas the classic version does not
skittles gummies okay first glance it
feels like they're taking away the
skittliness of it i mean they're making
just round gummies now what's important
skittle gummies and like other food
flavored gummies and how much does the
shape affect the taste look like oh my
god how many greens i pulled out in one
pinch
yep
i'm a sucker for gummy i don't know why
i love gummy stuff these aren't very
good i know gummy snacks are maybe the
most unnatural delivery system for
flavors but these taste woefully
manufactured why are my gummies sweaty
scales they get a little more to learn
about gummy manufacturing because these
just use their net the boys in sweden
are still kicking your butts with their
fish sorry then we're on to the final uk
exclusive which is this skittles stixx
ice cream bars the back of the packet
describes them as fruity flavoured ice
cream with a secret sugar pearl center
bite into the whole thing
i feel like all of these are different
flavors of ice cream
and one of them i'm not enjoying and i
can't quite tell which one it is
skittles freezer pops you've been
sitting in my freezer for a month i'm
thrilled to get rid of them orange
because it's on the side here every
summer at the pool just trying to get
this thing open just sitting
take me back baby
those can stay in the past
last but not least these guys
singles to go little powder drinks make
some juice what's that real juice right
so you got these little flavor pouches
that's really funny they didn't even
bother the lemon they're like who cares
a little green apple juice who doesn't
love a little green apple juice
that's fun
yeah very natural looking
this is meant to be like put in a water
bottle
oh oh it definitely has a strong odor
finally they did it all the delicious
flavor of green apple candy
in your water
these are terrible you have to be
wondering the same thing that i'm
wondering
i would 100 have done this when i was a
kid the second to see this if i can put
them on one i'm gonna chug it oh it's
turning like a brownie barf color you
see that
[Music]
[Laughter]
this this right here is called taste in
the rainbow
[Music]
drink the rainbow
that one more
[Music]
like a fine wine
you can also get uh kosher skittles and
skittles gum
original skittles in the uk contain the
following
original skittles in the u.s contain
artificial colors like red 40 yellow 5
yellow 6 and blue 1 are restricted in
the uk because studies have linked them
to hyperactivity and attention deficit
in children food and drink containing
these things in the uk have to bear a
warning label about these potential
adverse effects which means that most
manufacturers will simply avoid using
them but not here also one chemical you
won't be eating in the eu anytime soon
is titanium dioxide the european food
safety authority found it could no
longer be considered safe when used as a
food additive specifically the panel
concluded that titanium dioxide
particles have the potential to induce
dna strand breaks and chromosomal damage
what
just feel my particles just
[Music]
breaking news coming to you live from
the food wars news desk shortly after we
recorded this episode mars ink was
actually hit by a class-action lawsuit
in the u.s the suit alleges that
skittles are unfit for human consumption
due to the presence of titanium dioxide
the suit points to the efsa ruling as
well as the fact that mars themselves
had committed to removing artificial
colours from their products back in 2016
i promise they've since backtracked on
mars isn't backing down just yet telling
the new york times that its use of
titanium dioxide is in compliance with
the strict quality and safety
requirements established by food safety
regulators including the fda we'll have
to wait and see how the trial unfolds to
see if there's any bearing on food
safety laws around titanium dioxide in
the us and potentially even the uk in
slightly better news standard skittles
do not contain any animal-derived
gelatin so they are suitable for vegans
in the uk a 45 gram bag of skittles
contains 179 calories this entire bag is
250 calories so we're going to quickly
count these out and figure out the
calorie count per skittle
how many skittles in a bag 52.
by my count a 45 grand bag in the uk
contained around 52 skittles that means
that the calorie count per skittle is
3.44 that's
4.24 calories per skittle as for sugar
content this tiny bag contains 66.4
percent of your recommended daily
allowance that seems like a lot gotta go
bigger in the us ours is 90
in the us they have bright side skittles
for when you're coming out of your cage
and you've been doing just fine
you know you
siblings folks going to town in a bag of
skittles just sitting around a table
eating in silence